john williams antwali says being jailed
by police for weeks at a time and
receiving death threats come with his
job here in rwanda
he's a journalist and youtube
broadcaster
he says the people he speaks to us
sometimes threatened too
here he's reporting on a community of
people who were evicted by police and
whose homes were bulldozed there were
houses
from this area they want compensation
several of rwanda's most followed
youtube broadcasters are already in jail
including some who reported on or were
critical of the evictions i'm focused on
justice
human rights and advocacy
and i know although the three areas are
risky and wonder
but
i'm committed to
john williams youtube channel's had more
than two million views since he started
it last year
it reports on things that can't be seen
on traditional media in rwanda
like the court appearance last month of
another youtuber a mable caracera
he was jailed last year and charged with
genocide denial after he spoke in a
broadcast about who'd killed members of
his family during the 1994 genocide
he told the court he was tortured in
jail denied his medicine for diabetes
and told that things would get worse
after rwanda hosted the commonwealth
heads of government meeting known as
chogham
and
leaders of commonwealth countries came
to rwanda's capital kigali for the
meeting last week
rwanda's government denies torturing
people and says its court proceedings
are fair contrary to many reports by
rights groups
president
was asked about rwanda's human rights
record in the closing press conference
there are no people who are in prison
that shouldn't be there
but there are people who are not in a
prison who actually should believe it
now the commonwealth meeting is over and
the leaders have gone john williams is
left wondering what's in store for him
those who try to speech to speak out
they are jailed
harassed intimidated or jailed
second
forced to free their country
three some of them
disappear in a thin air
or even
they die malcolm webb al jazeera kigali
rwanda